hey Siri do I have coronavirus more and
more tech companies are stepping up to
fight the virus from wearables to
contact tracing to developing at home
kits of course these inventions do not
replace safety precautions nor are they
intended to be a fix-all but technology
can make a difference in combating the
virus spread for one Apple and Google
are teaming up to build a contact
tracing feature for their phones which
would use Bluetooth to track physical
proximity between phones and hence their
users this would all be on an opt-in
basis so if you're one of the users who
tested positive for kovat 19 you could
report it through the app and then users
who are in recent contact with you would
get a notification for you scream
concerns of privacy and practicality the
tech giant's are working on that with a
beta version available for developers
now besides contact tracing Apple is
also offering resources to screen your
symptoms through its website or through
Siri but if you're not in the Apple
ecosystem and owned an Amazon Alexa
product if you think you have kovat 19 I
can ask you a few questions based on CDC
guidelines you can also ask the voice
assistant to play a song for 20 seconds
while you wash your hands happy birthday
happy birthday you get the point along
with the collection of screening
services there's also been a rise in
maps and dashboards Facebook released a
map of people in the United States who
have reported kovat 19 symptoms the data
is from surveying more than a million
Anonymous participants and the map
breaks it down by each county Facebook
and Google also developed mobility
dashboards showing how movement has
changed in places like supermarkets and
transit stations wearables have also
become popular for earlier health
detection more than 2000 health care
workers at the University of California
San Francisco campus have received a
Nora smart ring this ring has technology
to track changes in body temperature
heart rate and sleep the goal is to
identify frontline health care
professionals who may be infected before
they become symptomatic eventually
researchers hope to gather enough data
to develop an algorithm for Kovach 19
detection artificial intelligence is
also assisting frontline healthcare
workers technology giant Alibaba is
using AI to speed up the process of
analyzing CT scans this process normally
takes up to 15 minutes
Alibaba says the AI shortens it to a max
of about 10 seconds and in mid-march
said it had already analyzed over
240,000 CT scans while maintaining a 96
percent accuracy rate this technology
has been tested in hospitals in China
and Alibaba hopes to expand its usage to
Europe 23andme is also conducting
research of its own a genetic study of
course its goal is to obtain over 1
million responses and analyze genetic
factors that might be associated with
kovat 19 to understand why some
experience more severe symptoms than
others this research will also consider
non-genetic factors like age obesity
pregnancy and prior exposure other tests
that will slowly come to the market are
at home kits Everly well has been doing
at home kits for many health concerns
from fertility tests to allergy tests to
HIV tests its latest kovat 19 at-home
test is not yet available to the general
public but it is working with the FDA to
meet guidelines and is offering bulk
order options to hospitals and health
care providers the way these at home
tests would work is you
take an online questionnaire to see if
you qualify to receive a kit once
approved this $135 kit will be mailed to
you within 48 hours of the lab getting
your sample you'll get your results
digitally if the results are positive
there's telehealth available to inform
you on next steps there are many more
companies making big and small steps to
fight cope at 19 and we will continue to
see more in the future but in the
meantime stay healthy use these tools if
applicable and follow instructions we
all have a part in this
[Applause]